la biscuiterie maison la varenne situé à
versailles est l'un des cent lieux
choisis par christelle pigeons sa
particularité la responsable a repris
les recettes du chef de cuisine qui
officiait sous louis xiv adaptés à la
clientèle d'aujourd'hui ce lieu plein de
poésie mélange gastronomie et histoire
la dame qui dirige cette biscuiterie
confierez il ya le corner qui était
passionné d'histoire et en fait elle a
pris les recettes de cuisine du
cuisinier la marraine qui officiait sous
louis xiv et les arts traduite du vieux
françois pour proposer aujourd'hui aux
clients de manger les mêmes gâteau que
manger louis xiv louis 15 pour lui celle
dont je trouvais le concept vraiment
original et assez insolite et pour
trouver ces lieux insolites l'auteur a
travaillé pendant un an grâce au bouche
à oreille et aux offices de tourisme le
livre de 160 pages est illustré de 300
photos et de permettre au lecteur de
découvrir les richesses du territoire où
qu'il soit curieux faut qu'ils aient pas
peur d'aller aussi bien visiter le parc
aux étoiles où on parle que d'astrologie
que le musée des petits trains ou nyassa
ce n'est que pour les passionnés de
petit train
enfin voilà il ya j'ai essayé de mettre
des choses déjà quitté de temps tout le
département
parce que comme je disais département
est grand et en même temps qu'ils
puissent plaire à tout le monde
les familles les amoureux les gens qui
aiment la littérature l'art yvelines son
lieu pour les curieux et à découvrir aux
éditions bonneton une séance de
dédicaces est organisée samedi 13 mai à
la maison de la presse au vésinet